♪ ♪
>> Greg: CLAPPING HAS BEEN
BANNED IN BRITAIN'S UNIVERSITY
OF MANCHESTER.
CLAPPING BECAUSE IT TRIGGERS
ANXIETY AND DISCOURAGES PEOPLE
FROM ATTENDING EVENTS.
AND IT WILL BE REPLACED WITH A
SILENT VERSION OF JAZZ HANDS
WHICH IS SAID TO ENCOURAGE AN
ENVIRONMENT OF RESPECT.
TOTALLY DIFFERENT STORY.
A MASSACHUSETTS PROFESSOR SAID
THE LABEL VETERAN SHOULD BE
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE PEACE
ACTIVISTS.
I SAY THE LABEL PROFESSOR SHOULD
BE EXPANDED TO INCLUDE MESSY
DROOLERS.
THEY HAVE BOTH BROKEN OUT OF THE
ASYLUM GATES OF THE LOCAL
UNIVERSITY.
NO ONE WANTS TO SAY MAN, THAT'S
REALLY DUMB.
WE ARE ALL BULLIED INTO SILENCE
BY THE TYRANNY OF GRIEVANCE.
NOBODY WANTS TO SHARE THE RISK
IN CALLING OUT ABSURDITY BECAUSE
THAT MAKES YOU A BIG MEANIE.
YOU'RE ON A SUBWAY AND A MANIAC
IT'S ON.
EVERYONE, WHAT DO THEY DO?
THEY LOOK AT THEIR PHONES.
BECAUSE NO ONE WANTS TO ASSUME A
PIECE OF RISK.
THEY HIDE FROM THE MANIAC.
THEN HE REALIZED THE MANIAC IS
BILL de BLASIO.
HE IS SCREAMING.
YOUR HEADACHES.
NOW THE JOKE IS ON YOU.
YOU SHOULD HAVE COMPLAINED THE
MOMENT de BLASIO GOT ON
YOU SHOULD HAVE SAID SHUT UP.
WHEN EVERYONE LOOKS THE OTHER
WAY, IN CONGRESS, ON-CAMPUS COME
IN THE MEDIA MAYBE IT'S ONCE
TIME TO SHARE THE RISK.
MIGHT BE THE ONLY DEFENSE WE
HAVE LEFT.
JESSE, THEY SAID CLAPPING MAKES
THE UP WITH AUTISM NERVOUS.
I THINK THERE WAS A STRATEGY TO
USE A REAL ISSUE TO CAMOUFLAGE A
SILLY IDEA.
IF CLAPPING MAKES ARTISTIC OR
ANY ANXIOUS PEOPLE NERVOUS, IT
WOULD BE HARMFUL TO KEEP THEM
FROM BECOMING ACCUSTOMED TO IT.
WHAT IF THEY WANT TO GO TO A
SOCCER GAME OR A ROCK CONCERT.
THEY CAN'T BECAUSE THEY WOULDN'T
BE USED TOOK CLAPPING.
THIS IS ABSURD.
>> Jesse: ARE YOU SURE THIS
ISN'T AN ONION ARTICLE?
>> Greg: I DOUBLE CHECKED.
I SHOULD CHECK WITH THE
PRODUCERS.
>> Jesse: CLAPPING ISN'T
REALLY FOR THE PEOPLE CLAPPING.
IT'S THE PERSON PERFORMING.
FOR INSTANCE, MYSELF.
WHEN I AM ON STAGE, I NEED THE
CLAPPING TO KNOW IF MY JOKES ARE
LANDING, TO KNOW IF I HAVE THE
AUDIENCE ON MY SIDE.
I NEED THE AFFIRMATION.
THEY ARE MISSING THAT.
ALSO --
>> Greg: IT IS ALL ABOUT
JESSE.
>> Jesse: THE BRITISH ARE
OVERLOOKING SOMETHING ELSE.
HOME TEAM ADVANTAGE.
WHEN YOU HAVE A LOUD CROWD, IT
FORCES THE OPPOSING TEAM INTO
TAKING TIMEOUTS AND THEY MISS
COMMUNICATE.
TO YOUR POINT ABOUT AUTISM, THIS
DISCRIMINATES AGAINST BLIND
PEOPLE.
BLIND PEOPLE CAN SEE JAZZ HANDS.
GETTING TO THE AUDITORY
SITUATION, THERE WERE SOME LOUD
NOISES AROUND WORLD WAR II WHEN
THE GERMANS WERE DROPPING REALLY
LOUD BOMBS ON THE BRITISH AND I
THINK THE BRITISH, I THINK THEY
SURVIVED.
THE ANXIETY IS REAL ANXIETY AND
THEY METED OUT.
>> Greg: JUAN, WHAT DO YOU
MAKE ABOUT THE IDEA OF PEACE
ACTIVISTS BEING CALLED VETERANS?
>> Juan: I THINK IT'S A GREAT
IDEA.
DIPLOMATS.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT PEACE
ACTIVISTS.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN DIPLOMATS,
NEGOTIATORS FROM PEOPLE WHO MADE
AN EFFORT, EVEN PEOPLE HAVE GONE
OVERSEAS LIKE WITH THE PEACE
CORPS, THE MORMONS.
>> Greg: THAT IS NOT A
MILITARY VETERAN.
>> Juan: THEY DIDN'T SAY
MILITARY.
THEY SAID VETERANS.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE GIVEN OF
THEMSELVES.
>> Greg: SO I AM A TV VETERAN.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT IT, THEY GAVE OF
THEMSELVES.
THEY DID A JOB AND GOT PAID FOR
IT.
WHEN YOU PUT YOUR LIFE ON THE
LINE, CARRY A WEAPON, THAT'S A
VETERAN.
>> Juan: OUR SOLDIERS GET PAID
FOR IT.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE RISK TO
THEM, THE CLASSIC RISK-REWARD.
CHANCES ARE SOMEONE IS OUT THERE
LOOKING TO KILL YOU.
>> Juan: I THINK --
>> Jesse: WHEN YOU PUT A
BULLET IN BIN LADEN'S HEAD, YOU
ARE A PEACE ACTIVIST BECAUSE
BIN LADEN CAN'T GO TO WAR.
>> Greg: I THINK THE BIG
PROBLEM THESE DAYS IS NOBODY
WANTS TO SHARE THE RISK.
WHEN THERE IS A DUMB IDEA, THERE
IS A MINORITY OF ACTIVISTS THAT
ARE SO LOUD THAT THEY WILL
BOYCOTT YOU.
THEY WILL COME AFTER YOU AND
HOUND YOU.
PEOPLE GO, THAT'S A GOOD IDEA.
>> Dana: AS YOU WERE SAYING
THAT, ALL OF US FOR SO LONG,
WHEN WE HEAR THESE KINDS OF
THINGS, OH, THAT'S STUPID.
THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
BUT ALL OF ALL OF A SUDDEN,
THERE'S AN ENTIRE GENERATION OF
PEOPLE WHO THINK THAT YOU CAN'T
FUNCTION IN THE REAL WORLD
WITHOUT ALL OF THIS CODDLING.
>> Greg: THE SPEECH CODES ON
CAMPUS.
IN ACADEMIA, THEY DIDN'T WANT TO
SHARE THE RISK.
>> Dana: REMEMBER THE
PRESIDENT OF THAT UNIVERSITY IN
OKLAHOMA WHO STOOD UP AND SAID
WE ARE NOT YOUR BABYSITTERS.
WE ARE NOT YOUR PARENTS.
WE ARE HERE TO CHALLENGE YOUR
THINKING.
HE GOT ALL THE ATTENTION AND
MORE PEOPLE SHOULD BE LIKE THAT.
>> Greg: MANCHESTER UNITED HAS
THE LOUDEST SOCCER FANS.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE NOT DOING
JAZZ HANDS.
>> Juan: HAVE YOU EVER BEEN TO
GALLAUDET?
THEY ARE VERY AGGRESSIVE
PLAYERS.